so the Commissioner sent out this memo
to all the teams that shockingly got
leaked and I talks about there's gonna
be significant punishment here penalties
for these teams if you don't let the
network partners broadcasting partners
know the media and the opposing team I'm
looking for answers and Jeff Van Gundy
espn/abc NBA analyst is here to provide
those answers all right so what did the
Commissioner accomplished yesterday Jeff
with this memo to all the teams well I'm
not sure I think you have to wait and
see what what comes out of it but I do
think that Adam silver and the league
now is as player friendly and team
friendly as any commissioner you would
ever see in sport and right now those
players and teams are not giving back to
him the respect that he and the league
deserves and so I think he has to wield
a hammer much like David Stern would and
maybe even overreact because I don't
think his caring and kindness is being
reciprocated right now all right is
there a solution yeah play two games
that you're healthy to play yeah that's
a solution this idea I saw the LeBron
James and Kyrie Irving say yesterday
it's unavoidable
no it's not no I've watched it with my
own eyes guys play basketball there are
no victims here just volunteers and you
signed up to play 82 games knowing what
pro basketball requires and so now
fulfill your responsibility and play the
games you're healthy enough to play
it's not it's not a complicated you know
ESPN put out this statement yesterday I
read it's a complex issue no really it's
not it's not if you're healthy you play
this is what you signed up for to expect
as a player to get paid for 82 games
when you want to play 70 is not right if
we think as an elite now that things
have changed so much that 82 games is
not doable then the league
should scheduled you know sixty games
and the player should take a and the
owner should take a one-third cut but to
expect fans to pay for a substandard
product is wrong did the Spurs invent
this Jeff well it sort of evolved dan
like 20 years ago
teams would sit guys out maybe the last
game or two of us of a season right
before the playoffs and so you know it's
not like nobody ever rested you know
remember Pat Riley got I think they got
find way back when he was with the
Lakers I don't think he brought Magic
Johnson to Portland for a game late in
the year that used to be the norm and it
used to be considered okay I'm not sure
I even agree that's okay but what's
happened is the expansion of the rest is
now to such a point where people are
resting guys in the first month or two
months of the season not just late late
in the season so it's evolved and it's
grown and unless somebody puts a stop to
it and only only really can the owners
the players and the Commissioner do
anything about it they've got to get
together and understand partnership
connotates caring about the other people
in the situation so I was really
troubled by LeBron James saying there's
nothing the NBA can do because they
shouldn't be put in the position to have
to do he should understand I'm one of
the guys that people pay tickets to see
it's my obligation to play when I'm
healthy talking to Jeff Van Gundy
espn/abc NBA analyst but if you're
coaching now Jeff and you have a couple
players that are tired or you know that
you've had a lot of minutes here or
you've been on an eight day eight game
road trip or whatever it might be how do
you tell your players you I know you're
tired or I know you're banged up but I
need you to play for this game against
the Clippers on Saturday night on ABC
well first of all they weren't playing
like they had a day off they flew out
after their game Thursday night again
Utah they flew directly from Cleveland
after the game they landed there you
know Friday these guys Bron James is an
incredible athlete and he when he plays
he plays exceptionally well so the idea
that he couldn't be ready to play that
game it's far different that situation
was far different than the Golden State
San Antonio game as a coach I do think
though if a guy says to you hey listen I
don't feel I can help you tonight I
understand why a coach would would sit
him out what I disagree with is that
LeBron James was upset with their
decision if she wanted to play he would
have been on the floor yeah but also
trying to understand when somebody you
know if I'm the NBA and I'm saying wait
a minute who's sitting out and then how
do you you have a note from your doctor
that says Kyrie is really injured or
sick or Kevin Love is really sick or
injured like I don't know how you
enforce this other than to to guilt the
players and the owners and the GM and
the coach to say put your best product
out there because we have to think big
picture here guys yeah that's you know
you can go in there having independent
doctors and all that it's really they're
only about 20 guys that fans pay to see
the other fans you know the other
players are interchangeable not in play
but in you know ticket sales so you're
only asking you know X amount of players
you know I think listen if Tristan
Thompson and needs a very good player if
he decided to break his streak then sit
out a game I don't think you're gonna
hear about fans and it's wrong it's it's
the great Steph Curry
Russell Westbrook James Harden LeBron
James that's who that's who the NBA
markets that's what they say come and
watch these great athletes and so when
fans buy tickets to those games they
should expect to see those players if
they're healthy now every fan
understands the difference between being
disappointed over a real injury and
feeling outraged over being ripped off
when they just choose not to play I
don't think the fans I think fans
understand sometimes there's going to be
healthy
when were you guys told that the big
three were sitting out the Clippers game
um I think that was like maybe an hour
before the game in that in that
neighborhood but to me it's not about us
it is a business thing no our ratings
were down from last year same date I
think was 71 percent which as you know
Daniel but you're better media guide and
I would ever hope to be business wise is
like that translates into real money and
so a lot of the money being generated is
off the backs of the fans and the backs
of the TV deal I think we pay 1.4
billion a year to the NBA and if I was
Bob Iger and John skipper I'd be asking
for a rebate right now well I wonder if
the collective bargaining agreement was
up this year and these guys had to play
nice with the networks that you know
everybody cashed in here you know in the
offseason you had guys everybody got
paid and then all of a sudden you know
you got you got these guys who all of a
sudden are sitting out I don't I don't
know I and I don't know if there's a way
to enforce it I I think we're all in the
same page it's disappointing and you're
not going to grow the game if kids can't
tune into a Saturday night game because
they don't have school the next day and
the big three aren't playing against the
Clippers it's just it doesn't help the
long-term growth of this league well it
doesn't and again I don't understand
anybody who disagrees is that this is
what they signed up to do to play
professional basketball knowing full
well they played 82 games forever and
I'm all for a shorter season listen it
is a hard and demanding job without
question and but if we need to lower the
number of games I'm all for it I think
it would be a better product let's play
65 games let's totally eliminate
back-to-backs
and then get paid commensurate to that I
also think since that the max salary is
wrong because LeBron James should be
paid a hundred million dollars
compared to you know this artificial max
that we have in so listen I understand
you know the the idea that maybe 82
games doesn't suffice anymore and so I'm
for shortening the season to me though
you have to be willing to take less
money if you're a player on owner or a
coach or a GM for the shorter season you
can't have it both ways you can't get
paid for 82 games and show up for 70
what's your next nationally televised
game I am on the way to Salt Lake City
for the riveting and fascinating Utah
Jazz playing the New York Knicks I hope
everybody shows it well it may not
matter if everybody shows up well no
listen you know the next Saturday though
we have James Harden and Russell our
Sunday we have James Harden and Russell
Westbrook right yeah and they played
every game and so it really depends on
the mentality of the player thankfully
this Sunday we have two guys who want to
play and feel the obligation to play to
their teams to their fans and so should
be a great game safe travels thank you
Jeff tell barrini and Mark Jackson we
sit alone Jeff Van Gundy everything
sounds good in theory problem is I don't
know if anybody's gonna say layout take
less money here less games less money
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
brought to you by Continental Tire
designing tires to get you where you
need to go
they got award-winning tires Eco Plus
technology gained you miles save you
money the true contact to cross contact
tires they have a tire for what you do
Continental Tire is a proud supporter
the Dan Patrick show for more
information visit Continental Tire
combat the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you